January can be a bit of a boards raining  it's cold except if you're reading love  and a cold climate  lover Nicole climate was written by  probably one of my all-time favorite  authors Nancy Mitford it tells the story  of Polly Hampton and she's the only  daughter of two very aristocratic very  rich parents Polly claims to have no  real interest in any of the eligible  bachelors that she meets along the way  and her mother's getting extremely  frustrated with her but the truth is  that Polly has a very deep dark secret  when she finally reveals that secret  scandal ensues well this story is just  delightful it's not meant to be taken  seriously at all she is poking fun what  is essentially the people who she grew  up around I would say this book is is  for everyone  it does have somewhat racy content so  definitely not for for the under 16